-Now,
welcome back to the show.
I'm so happy that you're here.
I want to just kind of recap
what a year it's been for you.
-Yeah.
-Because we're friends
and we text each other
every now and then.
-Yeah. No, we do text.
-We do.
-It took me a long time
to get that phone number.
-I know.
-I had to battle it out.
-Did you really?
-And now my daughter is here,
kicked me out
of my dressing room.
-Your beautiful little daughter?
-Yeah. She goes --
I was, like,
standing in there, and she goes,
"Do you mind shutting
that door?" and made me go.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Indistinct ]
-Yeah, but isn't that fun,
though?
When you first came on,
you were just booking clubs
and hoping that
you'd book clubs.
-Oh, yeah.
-You sent me a text.
I go,
"Where are you playing tonight?
Like, what are you doing?"
You go, "No big deal.
I'm just doing the
Bridgestone Arena in Nashville."
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You broke the attendance record
with almost 20,000 people.
This is where they play hockey.
This is where they do --
-Yeah, yeah.
-Nate.
-It was -- It's crazy, dude.
-And your special's
the biggest show
in the history
of Amazon Prime,
which is --
It's all happening.
It's all so -- Yesterday,
in the last two days,
three sold-out shows
at Radio City Music Hall.
I mean, congrats, buddy.
I can't --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you. Thank you.
By the way,
that Bridgestone,
I stole one of the chairs
from Bridgestone.
-What do you mean you stole one?
-Because I have the record.
So if I take one
of the chairs home,
no one can break that record.
-[ Laughs ]
-That is brilliant.
-Yeah.
-That is absolutely...
-You just cut right to it.
-You cut -- Yeah.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-It's unbeatable.
The special is --
I think my favorite joke
is the house joke.
You have -- You're living
in the house backwards.
-Yeah, yeah.
-But it's such a great --
I said the punchline.
It doesn't matter.
Watch it. It's worth it.
But also the fact that it blows
people's mind that you're clean,
by the way.
-Yeah.
-I watched it with my --
I watched it by myself.
I think I texted you.
I said, "Here's my notes.
I love this.
This is my favorite thing."
And then I watched it
with my dad
because it's something
I can watch with my dad.
So he was crying laughing.
It's so great.
You can watch it
with everybody.
We were laughing so hard.
You said because your dad,
I think, found a screen door
on the side of the road.
-Yeah.
-And then saw it.
-Put it in -- Yeah.
Put it in our house
and he put it on the wrong way
because the handle was on --
the handle is on this side
and the screen door
is on this side.
So if you came in our house
you had to go like --
you had to do that.
-[ Laughs ]
-And it was my mom.
My mom just wanted
a screen door
because she wanted it
to be normal.
She was like, "A normal family
in a home..."
This was the first home
they bought,
and it was in Old Hickory
and it was a two-bedroom home.
tiny, and she's like,
"A screen door,
we'd be a normal family
for two seconds.
Just give us a screen door."
And then my dad gets it
and it's just the most
not normal screen door.
-[ Laughs ] She still didn't get
what she wanted.
-Still did not get what she --
I don't know.
She still
doesn't have a screen door.
-But how is your dad doing?
I know he's been opening up
for some of your shows.
-He was just here. He does --
I mean, he's been great.
You know, it's every
little boy's dream,
travel with your dad when you're
44 years old.
[ Laughter ]
It's...
-That's it. Wow.
It really is a dream, yeah.
-I got a tour bus with
a CPAP machine hooked up, so...
[ Laughter ]
...it's pretty good times.
We're out there mixing it up.
-[ Laughs ]
You said that he's like
a prankster, right?
Your dad?
-Oh, yeah.
He did one to my brother.
His own son.
And Derek was getting all
his doors painted in his house,
so he took all the door
knobs off
and laid them in the living
room floor on a sheet.
And my dad went
and bought one extra doorknob
and put it in there.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-Just to slowly drive him crazy.
Your brother's like, "Wait."
-Well, he came back and like,
I mean, if you want to drive
someone crazy, do that.
Like, it's like,
"Where's the other door?"
Like, we're missing...
They're missing
a whole other door.
-It's a really funny prank.
-They almost got divorced
over it.
It's like, "What,
are you hiding doors from me?
What else
are you hiding from me?"
You know? Yeah.
-Things are going super well.
You started this new company
called The Nateland.
-The Nateland Company.
-Nateland.
-Nateland. And it's
a production company.
You're making family-friendly
comedy specials
on YouTube right now.
-Yeah, right now the showcase is
on Nateland Entertainment,
YouTube.
The showcase is out.
-Nateland?
-It sounds as if
you said Nate-lind.
-Nateland. I say Nateland.
-No, you didn't.
[ Laughter ]
-When?
-I think he said Nate-lind.
I said Nateland,
and you go "Nate-lind."
And I go,
"Oh, was I saying it wrong?"
-Well, that might be my accent.
That shouldn't count
as me mispronouncing it.
You should be able to
read through and go,
"He doesn't even know
what he's talking about."
Like, that's --
-No, I just didn't know if
I was saying it wrong.
I wanted to make sure
I'm saying it correctly.
-I think anything I say
you could be like,
"You probably said it right."
I told you I think you say our
last name correct
with "Bar-got-see"
and I think we say
it wrong as a family.
[ Laughter ]
"Bar-get-see."
-For years I've been
calling you Nate "Bar-got-see."
-Yeah, and I just went with that
'cause you were so big
it was easier just to --
[ Laughter ]
It's just easier to do
whatever you choose. You go...
-I don't want
to name you, though,
but your name is Nate Bargatze.
-Marc Maron once called me Nick,
and I was like,
"I'll just be Nick."
Like, it's already -- It was
enough people that was Nick,
I was like, "I'll just go
with whatever's out there."
-The tour, the special,
the new company --
you got a lot going on.
Is it hard to keep
track of everything?
-Yeah. Yeah. I mean,
it's all getting crazy now.
And we live, you know --
it's like as I get older,
it's like, I don't know.
Like, we live
in a neighborhood.
We live in a cul de sac,
and we're the house at the top,
so we are the leaders
of the cul de sac.
But, like, all my neighbors
are all like,
they all have real jobs.
You know, when you're, like,
around people with real jobs?
Like, I don't know
anything about taxes.
I get asked about
my property taxes every day.
Just some guy, you know,
and I'll just say --
I just say,
"They are what they are."
You know, you just...
-That's a good answer.
-I told --
One guy wouldn't let up
because he was moving
to Nashville,
and I was like, "100 --"
I just told him $100,000,
and he was so mad.
So I thought,
"Alright, too high."
And I said, "$85 a month."
And he was like, "What?"
And I go, "What?
What do you want them to be?"
[ Laughter ]
Do you see my wife here?
I don't know if we own
or rent our home.
I've never asked
any of these questions."
Like, yeah.
-You're not supposed to know
those things.
-I don't know this stuff.
-No.
Do you have, like, a --
Do you have a lawyer?
-No. I always think
you should want a lawyer.
Don't you see on TV?
Did you see that growing up?
Everybody'd be like,
"Call my lawyer."
-Yeah.
-And then they --
And you're like, "Are we
supposed to have a lawyer?"
Like, I don't like...
I just call him,
I get my lawyer on the phone.
They have one.
I've never had one.
I don't know
any court stuff either.
Like, I think I got --
I got to miss out
on jury duty because of COVID.
But I was very scared
about going
because I'd never understand
that the jury is there,
and the judge tells the jury,
"Alright, well,
don't remember that part."
And you're like,
"That's the only part
I'm going to remember now."
[ Laughter ]
Like, it's like the main...
-You can't tell me to not --
-"Remember when he said
he did it for sure?
Don't remember that part."
You're like, "Alright."
-If you want a jury,
don't never have Nate Bargatze
or "Bar-got-see" on your jury.
Nate Bargatze, his special,
"Nate Bargatze:
Hello World" is streaming
now on Prime Video.
You won't be --
It's unbelievable.
It really is an all-timer.
I'm so happy for you, buddy.
Thanks so much for coming back.
-You're a big part of it.
-I love you, buddy.
-Thank you. Love you, buddy.
-Stick around.
Be right back with more
"Tonight Show."
Come on back, everybody!